but going back to anime yeah going back
again i appreciate we're exciting so
much more
uh we obviously i don't know if you i i
watched like two episodes of yasuke
that was that was pretty good the voice
acting i really enjoyed i need to watch
that as well
um from two episodes i wasn't really
sold on the story
again i knew about the if you don't know
about yasuke the plot is about
essentially
uh nobunaga uh way back in the edo
period uh
had single period single computer sorry
singapore period had
uh just met a black guy at a market and
was like i want him to fight for me yeah
and he was based on a real
person as well yeah and was one of his
closest uh
like allies i guess he was very and the
story kind of explodes
expands on it but i saw a bunch of this
on youtube
yeah i thought this would be a [ __ ]
badass anime [ __ ] you're not like two
weeks later
got announced on netflix and i was like
wow i guess i should start wishing for
things yeah
yeah it was really it's really there's i
highly encourage you to go read up about
it it's super interesting
and you just wouldn't expect it it's uh
it's also done by sean thompson
by lashawn thomas yeah i don't know who
the animation studio is
but oh is it map but i do think that
if you want to learn act this is not
like the best at explaining at least
from the first two episodes i was like
this is
wildly different uh from because i mean
you said there was like magic there's
magic there's mechs and stuff and it's
like i'm like i'm pretty sure that
didn't
exist in feudal japan oh yeah i mean
that was literally showing thomas going
[ __ ]
in some aspects i'm also like this is
such a [ __ ] badass story
by itself yeah that it doesn't need
anything added it's so goddamn like
the best parts of like again i've only
watched two out of six the best parts
the first two episodes
where the parts were like free because
there's a there's a time skip
pre-time skip where there's like no
magic or [ __ ] where's your fighting
sword to sword
man-to-man combat it's so goddamn good
and the story and it builds on all
though obviously because
you know back then it could be a lot of
issues with race with that stuff of
course
yeah of course yeah they weren't too
happy about it when nobody was like this
is my best friend yeah
um you know and building on that was so
interesting and i thought like the best
parts anime were that and uh again yeah
i
the story is just so cool like don't
read up about it there's tons of youtube
videos about it
i actually i actually like went and like
[ __ ] researched so [ __ ] like the
real life yesterday just because like i
had no fun
it's a badass story oh yeah that's
[ __ ] badass yeah it's it
it's like it's just stupid it could be
fictional like
you feel like the mech and magic aspects
added to that story or do you think it
felt out for me personally i didn't
really enjoy it like
i wanted i was hoping you
the music in the first two episodes is
pretty [ __ ] good yeah yeah exactly
really good the voice acting top [ __ ]
notch even in the japanese it's really
good and like uh you know even in the
japanese jazz game
is played by a black japanese guy which
oh okay awesome
it's normally not on the priority list
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
you know it's really cool seeing that
you know why why wouldn't you want that
um
yeah i mean everything else about it i
was digging everything i i
you know i haven't really been motivated
to watch the rest of it
right i think that's because the max
thing is going to put me off in the
magic and stuff
i mean the short clips i watched of it
was [ __ ] it
like i didn't realize it was like gonna
be that [ __ ] bloody and gory as well
ah dude it's good
like some of the scenes like reminded me
of like a 90s over like ninja scrolls
like levels
sometimes yeah it was like kill bills
ninja scroll like levels of like oh
oh that's oh that's brutal it's so good
i love it
yeah yeah i still haven't seen it but i
i gotta check it out
i will definitely check it out you'll
know if it's for you in the first two
episodes like i really like the sean
thomas's work anyway so i was going to
watch it
just it's just hard to find time with
all the [ __ ] anime are in the season
and
everything right which you two don't
know about carl i've been meaning to
watch a bunch i've been meaning to watch
86.
86 is actually really yeah i i
i probably say that's my favorite oh i
can't say favorite it's it's hard
it's it's definitely top top three of my
favorite anime out this season right now
and it just it just feels good to have
an original mecca show
that just gives me the same feeling as
like some of the og mecha shows that
made me really really like the genre
because it feels like it's been so long
since we've just had a non-gundam
non-code geass or non-big franchise
mecca show that true has actually been
really really good because most of the
mecha shows i remember that's been
coming out recently have either been
like darling in the franks where i get
invested and it
kind of does [ __ ] that falls flat or
like i really enjoyed great
trigger is like well then you've had
things like
uh sss grid man which [ __ ] amazing
show but it's like
it's a mecca show but it's also a bit
toka satsu so it's not like it's it's
it's it's like it's like
it's not like a vanilla make a show
right yeah yeah
yeah but 86 you know gives me the same
feelings of when i was when i will first
watch code gyas
i reckon seven or the mechs that i
watched in the mid 2000's that really
made me
love the [ __ ] genre um it's still
early days i don't know if it's gonna be
like 24 episodes or 12 episodes where
there's going to be a complete
story i'm really hoping so but it's just
really really good
i mean do you know do you know the story
of it at all i don't want to know
anything oh i've heard that's good
yeah i'm gonna watch it yeah yeah yeah
just going to a blind is the best way i
think